die queen und nelson mandela verband
eine wahre freundschaft so heißt es
daran erinnert man sich gerne dieser
tage viele in südafrika betrauern den
tod der monarchien loben ihre integrität
doch es gibt auch andere stimmen in
einem statement der oppositionspartei ff
heißt es unsere beziehung zu
großbritannien unter der führung der
britischen königsfamilie war eine von
schmerz und leid tod und enteignung und
die humanisierung von afrikanern und
weiter falls es wirklich leben und
gerechtigkeit nach dem tod gibt mögen
elisabeth und ihre vorfahren bekommen
was sie verdienen die königin
repräsentierte das system das die
verantwortung trägt für die apartheid
und die kolonialzeit und sie war sehr
wohl politisch aktiv
sie war ein mensch der aktiven politik
verwickelt war aktiv im kommen war ihre
persönliche mission und ihr bestreben
waren eindeutig dass kommen wolf
zusammenzuhalten aber wo sie versagt hat
war die moralische verantwortung für die
kolonialzeit zu übernehmen das hat sie
nicht getan und deshalb viele gedrängt
viele hier sagen man bedauere den tod
des menschen nicht aber den der königin
sie steht für ein system des
imperialismus der unterdrückung viele
haare unter diesem system gelitten
sie haben uns mehrfach unseres
wohlstandes beraubt südafrika könnte
ohne sie viel weiter sein
auch kenia ist einstige britische
kolonie getöteten soldaten des british
empire während der marmor rebellion
tausende kikuyu sie hatten sich dagegen
gewehrt dass man ihm irland weg nahm
hunderttausende wurden in lager gesperrt
das alles geschah während queen
elizabeth auf dem thron saß
ihr tod wird die vergangenheit zurück wo
sie an ich war damals aber wir haben
viel gelitten unsere väter onkel
verwandten wurden in lager gesperrt oder
getötet es sind viele bittere
erinnerungen
für bitterkeit sorgt auch der cullen in
diamant in zwei teile gespalten schmückt
der die königskrone und das zepter der
stein wurde 1905 in südafrika entdeckt
er ging als geschenk so heißt es an
könig er bot doch damals war südafrika
britische kolonie der rohdiamant hatte
ursprünglich mehr als 3000 karat gebt
den diamanten zurückfordern viele er
wurde gestohlen so der vorwurf
sie sollten uns zumindest für den
diamanten entschädigen es heißt er sei
400 millionen dollar wert falls wir
etwas zurück bekämen könnten wir das
hier gut brauchen wir haben selbst nicht
viel
die spuren der kolonialzeit und
apartheid prägen südafrika bis heute
zumindest eine entschuldigung der person
die all das repräsentierte hatten sich
viele gewünscht vergebens